los principales actores en el sector de
la cultura actúan para aislar a moscú
tres grandes estudios son y disney y
warner bros suspendieron el estreno de
sus películas en el país además rusia no
podrá competir en el festival de la
canción de eurovisión
2022 facebook tick tock y microsoft
están tomando medidas contra los medios
de comunicación respaldados por el
kremlin como 'russia today' sputnik tras
la decisión de la unión europea de
bloquear su emisión el mundo del deporte
también ha recibido un golpe importante
este lunes especialmente en el fútbol
tras las decisiones iniciales adoptadas
por el consejo de la fifa y el comité
ejecutivo de la uefa que preveían la
adopción de medidas adicionales la fifa
y la uefa han decidio hoy conjuntamente
que todos los equipos rusos ya sean
equipos representativos nacionales o
equipos de clubes serán suspendidos de
la participación en las competiciones de
la fifa y la uefa hasta nuevo aviso la
uefa también dijo que ponía fin a su
acuerdo de patrocinio con el gigante
energético ruso gazprom el aliado de
moscú belarús también está sintiendo las
consecuencias el comité olímpico
internacional instó a los organismos
deportivos a excluir a los y
funcionarios rusos y los rusos de todos
los eventos internacionales la final de
la liga de campeones de este año se
traslado de san petesburgo a parís
mientras que el gran premio de la
fórmula 1 en sochi también se canceló
por otro lado el presidente vladimir
putin fue despojado de su cinturón negro
honorífico de taekwondo y el güero
taekwondo acusó al ejército ruso de
cometer ataques brutales contra vidas
inocentes